ملف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه ايضا كشف
مصدر امني مطلع ان ايران زودت روسيا سرا
بكميات كبيره من الرصاص والصواريخ وقذائف
الهاون في حربها على اوكرانيا وتخطط
لارسال المزيد واضاف المصدر ان السفينتي
شحن يطلق عليهما موسى جليل وابكي ترفعان
العلم الروسي غادرتا ايران بين العاشر
والثاني عشر من يناير متجهتين الى روسيا
عبر بحر قزوين وتحملان ما يقرب من مئه
مليون رصاصه وحوالي 300 الف قذيفه وبحسب
المصدر يعتقد ان السفينتين كانتا تحملان
نحو 200 حاويه شحن مليئه بالاسلحه واكد
المصدر نفسه ان الذخيره الخاصه بقاذفات
الصواريخ وقذائف الهاون والمدافع الرشاشه
كانت مدرجه في الشحنات مضيفا ان موسكو
دفعت ثمن الذخيره نقدا والى جانب الدعم
الايراني يتزايد القلق في العواصم الغربيه
بشان احتمال ان تبدا الصين في تزويد روسيا
بالاسلحه وهي خطوه حذره الولايات المتحده
من انها ستكون لها عواقب وخيمه على بيكين
فيما نفت الصين هذه المزاع